what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to comics requests Monday
it has been a long time but now that we
finished time runs out now that Secret
Wars is on its way in now that we're
done with the age of Ultron and all that
stuff we could finally get back into
this series so for those of you guys who
are unaware the comics request Monday
series is a weekly series where I
basically make videos on your most
requested characters and teams and so in
this video what we're going to be doing
here is we're gonna be focusing on Brock
rumlow otherwise known as crossbones now
the way that we're gonna explain his
character in this video is him we're
simply gonna go with his origin story
we're gonna go with how it was it he
appears in Marvel Comics and the reason
for this is because with Brock rumlow he
really only has two significant moments
in Marvel Comics the first comes in the
form of of course his appearance in
Marvel Comics with Captain America vol 1
issue number 359 but this second is
actually the death of Captain America
event and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna kind of turn this into a
crossbones slash death of Captain
America discussion because with Captain
America to the Winter Soldier with
Captain America a civil war as well as
the agent Carter TV show we pretty much
have all the makings for a death of
Captain America event in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so the origin story
of crossbones was given to us in backup
features - Captain America vol 1 issues
number four hundred and four hundred and
three with issue number four hundred
what we find here is that Brock rumlow
was previously the leader of a gang in
Hell's Kitchen New York called the
savage crimes now among the members of
this gang were two men the first man was
Ricky Layton and the second man was
Daniel E and of course they were
brothers here now these two men aren't
necessarily wildly important to the
ongoing actions of Brock rumlow with
regards to him being in a gang and his
actions later on in Marvel Comics but a
person who is very important here is
Rachel Layton the sister of these two
brothers and the reason why is because
with this initial origin story what
Marvel does is they give us a very good
indication of the kind of man that Brock
rumlow was what we find out here is that
Rachel Layton had always been trying to
follow her brothers around she'd always
been trying to I guess maybe engage in
the same kind of action her brothers
were engaging in so with him being in a
gang her goal was to basically I guess
become initiated into this
named gang and so the result was that
she had met with Brock rumlow alone now
Marvel doesn't explicitly tell us this
what they do here is they imply what it
is it happens next what they indicate is
that when Rachel Layton meets with Brock
rumlow alone that he basically forces
her into a basically into sexual
intercourse he effectively rapes her and
then he beats her which of course the
result is that when when her brothers
Ricky and Daniel realized what it was
that Brock rumlow had done and they try
to attack him and kill him but the
result is that in the conflict Brock
rumlow kills Ricky and of course as we
know with Daniel he later on becomes an
assassin for hire called cutthroat now
an issue number 403 the story sort of
continues where this particular instance
left off but it's very limited here
Marvel doesn't give us a whole lot of
information regarding the youthful
actions of Brock rumlow
aside from his involvement in this gang
what they tell us here is that somewhere
along the line that Brock rumlow had
basically become a instructor and
taskmaster school for criminals
taskmaster was effectively a villain who
was able to mimic the fighting style and
the memories of anybody that he was
competing against and so the result was
that he was prodigious in his fighting
style and so Brock rumlow again is
someone just just given to us as his
person who was an instructor and when
Rachel Layton is basically brought to
this school she immediately recognizes
Brock and then leaves in order to
basically avoid a confrontation between
the two of them and that's really all we
get we don't really get anything more
aside from that and these old stories
now following crossbones initial
appearance and Marvel Comics and his
subsequent appearances war Marvel did
was basically established him as a
character to round out the various
villains of Captain America's rogues
gallery with characters like Red Skull
and even Baron hell muse emo most of the
challenges Captain America faced were
mental challenges or else simply just
defeating an almost insurmountable wave
of villains that were sent after him by
Red Skull or Baron hell new Zemo or
something like that very rarely did we
ever actually see Captain America able
to go toe-to-toe with a consistent
villain this all really changed with
crossbones crossbones was a character
that repeatedly went after Captain
America over and over again but because
of crossbones previous military training
because
his training at the taskmasters Academy
his fighting style his strength his
speed his endurance they were all almost
on par with Captain America and so while
he wasn't able to go toe-to-toe with
Captain America for the long haul he was
able to hold his own hold his own quite
a bit and even in several instances
actually overpower Captain America now
going into the events post-civil war but
that is to say with the death of Captain
America event and the surrender of
Captain America to shield forces once
can't go on once the Civil War was over
what we find here is that when we
discussed the return of Bucky Barnes and
our Winter Soldier video and Bucky
Barnes assassination of the Red Skull on
behalf of the Russians there prior to
the red skulls assassination he had
basically set in motion a plan to have
dr. Faust as the same person we had seen
from the agent Carter TV show basically
brainwash agent 13 Sharon Carter who is
benissa Peggy Carter and have her
assassinate Captain America now
initially when Bucky Barnes had
assassinated Red Skull it was believed
that Red Skull was dead and what we
learn with red seola see it actually
brought himself back to life using a
Cosmic Cube by taking over the body of a
Russian and then kind of inhabiting that
body for quite some time which is why
when we look at the death of Captain
America storyline we don't actually see
red skull with a red skull instead we
see him as a as a Russian general but
the fact remains here that this plan was
basically devised in two stages the
first stage was to have crossbones
operate as a sniper that would easily be
targeted or I guess easily be sighted by
Captain America and was really more of a
diversion for Captain America but what
crossbones would do is he would
basically shoot Captain America and then
create mass panic here the second part
of this stage was to have Sharon Carter
effectively deal the killing blow to
Captain America while everybody else was
distracted with with crossbones but the
other half of this was that because
Sharon Carter was a SHIELD agent
nobody would suspect that she's the
person that killed Steve Rogers and so
as we know with the death of Captain
America event the plan was a success
when Captain America was transferred to
the courthouse by a convoy of shield
agents and u.s. marshals
when he arrived at the courthouse he
immediately spotted crossbones but he
made no action to avoid being shot by
the result was that when crossbones had
shot Captain America a crate amassed
panic and in the mass panic Sharon
Carter killed Captain America and so as
we know we're I guess as the events
transpired following this particular
instance that crossbones is immediately
apprehended by shield but of course he's
broken out by by various supervillains
and so on and eventually goes back to
his life of being a killer for hire now
at this moment right now in Marvel
Comics with the continuity reboot that
they have going on with Secret Wars what
we presume is that crossbones died that
he did not survive the collapse of the
earth-616 continuity there Marvel hasn't
really announced any plans whatsoever
bring his character back in any form of
fashion but but they don't like
crossbones who was a mainstay for
Captain America for about 267 issues
he's pretty far from the top of the list
of people that fans just won a series
earn it's really just one of these
things where he's not one of the biggest
names out there in the realm of villains
and Marvel Comics with that being said
we're gonna go ahead bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]